cool
bj david welcome to the show thank you
atlas
thank you very much you for inviting me
i appreciate it
i'm so excited to have you on it's been
great
being with you in the no limit society
group
same here same here
yeah so much good stuff has come
to light from the
meeting of quite awakened
people and
willing to get to these next
steps of purification and of
igniting awakening around the planet so
it's really exciting what we have going
on
yes i agree totally
vijay's calling is people experiencing
absolute truth really excited to talk to
him about that
let's talk a bit about your journey too
about how you also
got to this
union with truth through the veilless
veil
the gateless gate and then we'll talk
about
naturally the absolute truth more and
more
so let's jump in from there
yeah also is that your phone
that's beeping can you silence it
oh sorry yeah i can't hear because
yeah yeah yeah but now it's it's muted
yeah
perfect perfect
yeah so shoot
what do you want to know
about yeah how was the union
walk us through the process of uniting
with
truth through the veils veil the
gateless gate
yeah normally
i'm not too good at somehow
making a good story out of it but let's
let's see what comes up this time
so um
a few years ago um
there was just some big decision i had i
had been
during my work career like i was doing
very normal
work courier in in the army
and in the commercial industry and stuff
like that
but somehow this kind of inner calling
started to emerge and
and i started to listen to osho's
teachings a lot
and then a few years ago me and my wife
decided to
just leave the whole whole paradigm of
the normal
work life and leave to to austria we had
a chance there
to to go there and
start to really investigate the inner
inner self
uh yeah it was quite intense after that
we both uh took part in
in this kind of uh year and a half
of show therapist training in denmark
during that time and also we had a
marriage crisis we have been married
since 2007
and because this kind of meditation
started to make things happen
so so we we went through a marriage
crisis but
from there started this really
big thirst for true the absolute
absolute truth like
really i want to go full on like
there was this one sentence from osho
when he said that
meditation has to become your whole life
yeah that was very powerful for me to
understand that it's not some
part part of life but it's
the whole thing
so then after some process
we we met muchi and uh
uh um osha was first like my master
and and then when when i started to
really resonate with mooji's teaching so
he became the number one
and i think he has been the best example
for me
about absolute truth and somehow this
absolute truth has become
my my password or some
some somehow the word that resonates
with me the most when i want to really
discover the
the ultimate what has what can be
discovered in this
human form in this manifest world i
think in a nutshell
it's like that so after that i've been
following mochi but
of course i have been then been
introduced with pentinio's beautiful
teachings which are so precise and so
beautifully represent
the same same calling so
here i am now with you talking about
it and
[Music]
what can i say that's what i breathe
and live for every single moment of my
life
waking life and i probably in the
dreaming life as well or sleeping life
so my whole life is dedicated for this
absolutely i love it i love
i love the
leaving of the conventional
algorithmic matrixy
life in search for the
infinite in search for the nothingness
in search for
the dying before you die
in search for uniting
with the absolute that we already are
but the noisy mind prevents the insight
so i love i love the leaving in order to
really like you said meditation has to
become your whole life
as osho said and it's great that you had
that
with your wife for 18 months
that sort of you said it was a therapist
training
right cool
yeah i mean it's you know it's called
like therapist training but i think
actually it's it's it's the inner the
inner journey
and also like very much integrated with
all the
physic physical stuff psychological
stuff
uh integrated in into also
this tapping into the non-duality
and yeah yeah
so i i wouldn't say that i'm a therapist
after that training
and then would you say
that as you were
then meeting muji and passing
more time diving deeper
into your union would you say that you
had a
a series of
pops how would you describe the process
of sort of moving from
person consciousness or from the
physical
to more of the subtle the awareness and
even the source of
awareness itself
yeah i think the most profound somehow
realization for me happened
um a little bit before i
i met muji that i was in a
in a vipassana silent retreat in
ocean center in miasto and
it was just really hardcore vipassana
following your breath
and sitting in silence many hours a day
and
it was really my first time to really
really go into any kind of meditation
process and stuff like that so
and i thought that it would be sort of
quite easy to be in vipassana for one
week but
actually to really see that
and go through all those battles that
that came in the mind like each is like
little
very normal stuff but but pain and
everything and to really go through it
and to really see
what happens somehow
that i'm not anything that i have
thought to
thought to be so i think that was sort
of like the first
real seeing that there that osha hasn't
been
talking [ __ ] that i can really
verify this thing myself
and after that i think when i when i met
buchi
he sort of brought it very precise this
kind of
um how this um
what they call it the pendulum goes when
you are in a
person mode and then you are in the
business mode
person mode and he was very well able to
say that
or somehow to describe and somehow i
could resonate with it that
i'm not either i'm not the person and
i'm not the
stable part but i'm the one who is
actually seeing it all
so there were of course i could say
a couple of esoteric experiences
walking with a dog and all of a sudden i
can realize that
everything is just consciousness that's
the whole
way of seeing the reality just change in
one second
and i can never go back to that anymore
so of course those type of moments are
always
exciting but then to actually start to
really see that not
no no experience or revelation is
actually nothing i'm all the time
the one perceiving it so
hard to describe it's it's like very
solid process of being in the
being in the big but seeing that the
person somehow goes like this
all over there so but it's very
beautiful process because it's
all the time expanding even though there
would be like
downfalls and ups and stuff like that
but
yeah i don't know if you could get
something out of that but
but but i would say that's pretty much
the
the process because uh moochie has been
saying this that
it's like cow jumping over the moon that
it's possible to go
over the whole mind structure like many
many people would say that spiritual
people who said it's like spiritual
bypassing somehow but you
go to the absolute witness and start
from there
not like going the person purifying and
purifying purifying then
at some point maybe you realize the one
the oneness but
actually to jump over that there and
then
seeing yourself going through this
purifying process and
i have found that to be a very fruitful
and
somehow very effective way
i love this there's so much here
so i also did vipassana
several times and that was very fruitful
for stilling the noisy mind
and really being able to get at these
deepest routes of aversion and craving
and then to extinguish those over time
and become
more and more equanimous and
become more and more tapped into the
very impermanent
anisha nature and
then as we
sort of follow that quote from earlier
that meditation becomes your whole life
you take what you learn
from that stilling process and you begin
bringing it like is said in tantra you
weave your realizations into the society
into the social fabric and
as you do so then
more and more you shift from
being reactive to everything
to just being having more of a pause and
being more still
and becoming more of the witness or the
observer or the awareness
itself and so you slowly become more
subtle and more formless and we move
away from this very
dense physical person
needing to be right needing to be
validated
needing to insert my point of view and
constantly
and so we move away from that and it's
really relaxing
it's really expansive and then over time
like you described with this great quote
and
osho and muji and bentino have been
massive influences on me as well
that as mooji describes that
you can undergo this process of
the cow jumping over the moon in the
sense of you can in a sense
get to the most direct
pointing of jumping straight to
being the one seeing it all and
over time becoming more and more like
what
right now this is not atlas
talking to a separate vj entity
this is one intelligence talking to
itself
and so it's it's a little bit of a shift
it's actually it's a big
shift but it's actually not that in a
sense hard to get through this
cow jumping over the moon veilless veil
in a sense
you just shift it from these being like
separate entities with their own
separate consciousness that are
having their separate identity and form
and all these things
and you shift it to their being one
intelligence
interacting with itself and that
awareness and intelligence and source
and all of that is
shared at play in a divine lila
and so that sort of shift is also
it's a pop also it pops you out of
being i'm going to be in my personal
awareness so even if you get to that
sort of formless
subtle awareness you pop again into the
impersonal
eternal observation and then
you become more and more of the one
seeing it all and then if you can really
pop
in this last one you can get to where
you recognize that the sense of
i itself even is an intoxicative
illusion it's the very first attribute
of the
shunya of the nothingness of the
emptiness of the void
and it's a it's very intoxicative to
to constantly be seeking relentlessly
the seeking impulse is the truest thing
about
us but at the same time the
idea of continuously non-stop
seeking forever is also
perverting that we could pop
people as these drill sergeants of
awakening
more and more rapidly into
yeah into and so this would probably be
a good place to
keep going with you is it seems like
you're sudden
because sudden and gradual with the
north and southern schools of zen have
been in dialectic for a long time around
which one is it and it's mostly a
synthesis that it's very gradual and
then there's a sudden pop and then it is
gradual again and another sudden pop and
then they sort of pick up
speed and then your boom you're
at the very nature of what you are
and so for you it seems like
the
first of all it seems like the sudden
pops were
that that's a that's a pretty accurate
way of of putting it and then another
way of describing it like you said it
was in a sense you're
going over the entire mind structure to
where there's no mind
and that's yeah so why don't you walk us
through
sort of that
can you give us also a quick timeline so
when
when did you leave the nine to five
in pursuit of absolute truth
uh it was 2015
summer cool when we made that
move okay
and then you would say that
so about five or so years of
seeking and to sort of undergo these
pops
into the absolute truth
yeah yeah you could say i mean
sort of sort of the process also
it's hard to anymore think think about
it at all
as some kind of linear process
in a way i think you know what i mean
but it's like uh yeah
yeah but yeah but yeah
maybe it's like it it sort of felt more
like a linear process for like
maybe three four years and and
then just no story makes sense anymore
after that
yeah and yet also the
story or the narrative or the road map
for awakening
the symbolization although in these
very last pops these last stages we
completely drop
symbolization at the same time the
symbolization and the story
and even though it's non-linear is
really important for this road map of
awakening to sort of find a
meta pattern across people so across the
mystic traditions across the modern
people that have undergone this process
and to sort of create something that
makes it so that people recognize that
oh i am moving away from
a very physical dense
attachment to identity and form to
something that
is becoming this formless subtle
awareness
and then making that impersonal eternal
and then
recognizing that even that's an
attribute of the ineffable
and that also this in itself
is the ineffable perfection just
perfectly
yeah yeah very well said and actually i
could maybe say that
somehow it feels that it becomes less
and less
interesting you could say this this how
it develops
somehow it feels like it's it's all the
play
play in the manifest and it's somehow
it's there's not so much
well there's some interest and
excitement about that too but not so
much like it's it's not so
i'm not following every day that's how
am i progressing today or something like
that
it's somehow because somehow it feels
like the whole manifest
is such amazing
mystery all the time that
my spiritual development in all of that
feels
like very somehow small thing also
yeah should probably be a
i've a couple points that i want to go
through right now
let's add this one because i liked it
manifest is such an amazing mystery
so
okay let's
talk about as you had the
i have two topics that i want to talk
about let's start with this one and
we'll get to the second one
as you had your
your very most recent
sort of direct pointings and awakenings
of the absolute truth with muji
and then encountering bentino and then
diving deeper and
how was that process so how did bentino
also assist further in what you had
already kind of popped
into absolute truth
yeah good good question i think um
somehow he was like such a beautiful
example because i had been following
mochi for for some while and somehow
that
i was thinking that what what kind would
be some kind of
optimal human being that i haven't seen
seen one for a while
and then i i just collided
how do you say it accidentally uh
in bentinus material and
it was so amazing the brilliance the
accuracy
and and then
the somehow how fast you can like like
talk about things and involve all these
manifest things and even esoteric and
the raw material type of
things like quickly and accurately and
also the psychological
structure what the human being has and
it was so beautiful it was
it started to feel like when i when
listening to him it's like
getting downloads so i think the
experience with painting here started to
be that
i can just listen to the guy and and i
get
downloads like i don't
it's a little bit different from from
the process with moochie where this
the process is to really
somehow pay the attention to the
to the being more and more and focusing
on that but
with bent in you somehow
it was some kind of purification of the
mind and downloading this kind of
material from the akashic record somehow
and
somehow just enjoy the fruits
automatically like plugging into the
thing and just listening to the diet
just so amazing so amazing and
how about you how did you how long have
you been with matt bentino
it's a really cool way to put it that
there's these different tastes and
flavors
of gurus and the truth coming
through them to
the
souls that are seeking to heal their
confusion and know their true nature and
so
[Music]
in a sense there's a
a taste that can be
directly pointing at the
nature of stillness
and silence and
experiential wisdom
with that and then there's also this
sort of
let's go through the seven densities
and so there are these different
sort of ways to add to your
lattice work of how you
interpret the nature and i love that a
lot it's been actually a core aspect to
what
has been going on for
this soul as well is the process of
sampling in the buffet as a synthesis
from these very core metaphysical truth
packages
and then putting it together into a very
robust
lattice work that can be very easily
navigated as lenses like a jedi
especially for
when those come to the soul asking
hey you know what do i do right now
and then when you've if you're not stuck
parroting a single teaching you know so
if you've only read
the sargatta you'll only parrot him but
if you've also
done muji and if you've also done
bentino if you've also
maybe you've also done some entheogens
you
have a wider buffet
in a sense that you can pull from and
especially if you've also analyzed
science and if you've analyzed form and
if you've analyzed business and
entrepreneurship
and art and creativity as well
biology neuroscience if you really
analyze these things
they add to your ability
for example when you take a look at
what is a
big bang followed by a evolutionary
process and
ascent that lands at a civilization
becoming self-aware
and then reflecting
on its true nature in an exploratory
leela divine play of that one
intelligence
and then that is a single
song in an eternal symphony
and so you can look at the very nature
of the cyclic cosmological exploration
you can look at it like a blink of an
eye
just that was it the whole thing went by
one more time so not only is it your
life
that's like 80 years like blink
done but it can be the whole big bang in
the whole ascensionary
exploration and so if you learn how to
you know treat your heart beat like
that same heartbeat of that cosmic
exploration
and then just go beyond the very nature
of
coming and going beyond the very nature
of appearing and disappearing
beyond the very nature of these births
and deaths
the more that you go beyond like that
the more that you commune with the
ineffable perfection
that you already are and that you're
appearing as this beautiful
vj and atlas soul costume
vehicle and it's great but it's an
appearance of eternity
and if you know that then
you don't commit malevolence the utility
the practicality is that you know it's
all one intelligence so
you become more and more in pure service
to other people rather than
being in service to your egoic
conditioning and
that maximizes the planetary potential
so bentino has been a massive
role in my shift into permanent
alignment
and so has the other
spiritual leaders that you've been
discussing throughout the program
and another good way to
hit the tennis ball to you would be
as you mentioned during one of our
recent and i think this is fascinating
you mentioned this during one of our
recent
family zooms where you basically
said that
how could it be that
this quote sense of i here
could be fully transparent
to itself to its true nature
and so it's it's a very humble and
beautiful way
to say that the mystery is so [ __ ]
ineffable
that how could i ever possibly get
through
all of the nonsense to be able to
truly commune with the taste of it
could you hit the ball back on that
good one
yeah i think it's this this is like
getting to the core
which is very good which is very good
um yeah how can this
how can how could this subject
be at all transparent i mean one thing
maybe i could still add of my spiritual
path what would i have been
also like incorporating into the mixture
is
is watching these non-dualists uh
um i don't know dude are you familiar
with tony parsons
and jim newman and those kind of
yeah we had jim newman on the show
tony's lined up i love them a lot too
yeah yeah i've been also in team
newman's retreat yeah
nice it's yeah so
i think they would probably laugh
hearing us talking right now but
um they'd be like good luck
[Music]
and maybe even the bentino side would be
something like
what is it within you that
makes you need to know
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
but i i i feel it's it's um
i can't only feel but but um
[Music]
it requires dedication to solve
that thing like to have really
this calling like i'm not i'm not
talking about my
process how i and my opinion how i feel
it has to be that the absolute truth has
to be in your heart that
it's it's such a
such a polar star that that you really
like bentino also says in his teaching
that you have to really go
to your actual experience which is
so much it's which is totally out of
your
intellectual like especially the thought
processes and
emotional processes and stuff like that
so at one point you see that
that is all in the
in the screen so you cannot possibly be
that but
also then to start
follow following your investigation
like more subtle more accurate all the
time and
at some point
when it's done you are really in the
pure pure the
pure i am place where you can
you cannot really say anything other
than there is just this consciousness
or consciousness whatever which is
everything and
at some point there when there is
only the subject pure subjectivity
this question arises can this also this
pure consciousness subjectivity be
observed
and
somehow then you could say it's
the whole subjectivity is transparent
which means
for example now that all that time
speaking and all this
is not like it's it's nothing like
it's it's it's it's nothing like in the
sense that intellectually i think it's
it's nothing or something but
because it's it's so seen through this
whole
whole thing here
but also you can't say like it doesn't
make sense or you can't take any
position to it
but what is the subject even then it's
somehow it
it also loses it's it's whole
whole relevance and somehow it just ends
up into this place where you
it doesn't matter anymore what you're
talking about or
what you're trying to achieve because
you can't get any there is no
possibility of
getting any further somehow
nowhere to get no from from where to get
or i mean the whole question has somehow
disappeared
because it's also it comes from thought
that there is actual thing called
subjectivity
and it's it's attached to some kind of
experience and
all that thing already is is
out in the screen so
it's impossible to talk about it i
but we are doing it so
yeah how do you say it's such a
funny it's a it's impossible to talk
about the ineffable yet
we're doing it right now yeah
because it's the coolest thing to do in
a sense
is to talk about what we truly
are and
is the conversation about the weather
equally as awesome as the conversation
about
infinity
[Laughter]
i would actually i would actually say
that i would most
rather to speak with you two or three
hours about this thing than my spiritual
history or something
even though you wouldn't get anywhere
but sorry i interrupted you
yeah i've noticed that the sort of
trajectory that also got people to where
they're at
is also important in
creating that said meta pattern of a
navigable road map
and so that being kind of part of the
core of trying to
assist people with symbolization that
helps them pierce the veilsville
gateless gate
and
that was beautifully said on your end
there's a
even in the psychological literature in
the
sort of self-help and the
self-development self-growth
self-actualization literature
that there's this focus on
becoming quote transparent to yourself
and so you
undergo the same process in these
self actualization literatures that the
mystics have been talking about for a
thousand years
which is to become hyper vigilantly
aware
of awareness to the point where you're
watching
every single frame and you're purifying
yourself
through these frames away from your
egoic conditioning
and more and more towards that very
nature of
god's love light that that absolute
truth
and then
those self-actualization and
self-realization
end up being two sides of the same coin
and
serving one another very profoundly and
deeply
ultimately one
so becoming transparent to oneself is
also
all over the scientific and
psychological literature so
what we're talking about is not just the
spiritual
idea but it's also deeply scientific and
pragmatic and
utilitarian is to become transparent to
yourself
basically the essence of the essence of
the question
is something like
it's something like this why do you do
what you do so become transparent
to your self your actions
your behaviors your patterns and in
doing so you get to this very first step
which is called know thyself
right the law of one has the sort of
three-step process of communing with
your true nature which is know yourself
accept yourself
and become the creator and so you have
to understand
why you do what you do in order for you
to know yourself frame by frame
because then you understand that
well why
do i feel
angry when my partner
does this specific thing what is it
that triggers me other people have
called this trigger surfing
so this is a very sort of long-winded
way of saying just
become a vigilant observer of your every
single frame
of your every action and shift
repeatedly
into permanent alignment with the one
intelligence
rather than serving your layers of egoic
conditioning
okay now you become more and more
transparent to your quote self
which is really important in the self
realization and self actualization
process
but then you get to the so-called point
and this is sort of where
i would say that i'm at right now
which is where you basically hit this
wall of the all-inclusive awareness so
when you begin recognizing that the
vj soul and the atlas soul and all these
eight billion units or costumes have the
shared all-inclusive great i am one god
self-awareness
and so you begin holding that more and
more and more
and then you begin playing with
transcending
even the purest subject
the very pure i am as vijay mentioned
you're holding this all-inclusive
awareness
consciousness pure i am
everythingness and then you ask
who or what is observing that
and then then you get to what buddha
called anata
no self and
what many of the greats have also been
calling
nothingness void shunya emptiness
you dance dance dance until
you get to the event horizon
of the black hole and
so i don't really know how to describe
this further but basically the sense of
i in essence is the most intoxicative
thing the most illusory thing so you
think that there's a sense of
i but it's really your own simulation
you
simulate you self-invent the sense of
i you simulate god you simulate the
all-inclusive awareness itself
to be able to be an observer or a
witness
of your infinite creation this being
just one
appearance of that and so what happens
when you go
beyond the all-inclusive observer
is the main question and so that's what
we're
talking about right now and that's that
that level
so you get so we can almost say there's
one level of transparency which has
become transparent to your actions and
your behaviors
and aka know yourself accept yourself
and so that part is mission critical to
become more aware of awareness and aware
of your frames and aware of when it's
the clouds appearing and disappearing
versus the sky
and then the second step in a sense is
to become
aware of the sense
of i itself
being self-invented
how does how does that sort of resonate
this
you know becoming transparent to
that first part and then becoming
transparent to even
that that second part
to such a degree where you even realize
that
the sense of i itself how could i
possibly know my
own mystery it
at that highest absolute level where
even the sense of i itself is simulated
so how could i possibly know
what it is if even the sense of i
itself is simulated how could i possibly
be transparent through that last
little taste
not an everyday question
in the local store
[Laughter]
actually that's actually one one um
effective thing what i have seen in in
the meditation
and everything is also that sometimes
it's very fascinating to
go somehow very deep into the
the layers and somehow the discoveries
and
conclusions and thoughts
but also at some point you see that
because
it's it's so so um
without any distance everything is so
much so perceived that it doesn't matter
whether you are
thinking about what are you gonna buy in
the
in the store i think in mundane things
like that or if you are really
deep in what this i am
can it be perceived somehow
somehow it at some point you see that
they
actually are exactly the same value
there's there's no more value in doing
this beautiful
work than thinking about
carrots and potatoes so somehow it's
it's
yeah like said jim newman and tony
parsons probably would
just laugh at those kind of things that
that it's but i i guess there's some
some something that you can get
through through those kind of things and
it's i'm not saying it's not
like it's it's totally useless to do
that
investigation i think it's actually it's
you have to i would in my opinion you
have to go
that deep as you were describing
in order for you to realize this this
thing that i said that there is
no distance to anything but you have to
somehow
make the contrast because before
the spiritual process you were only
thinking about potatoes and carrots
and they were their whole life and you
were thought thinking that
there's nothing beyond that but then you
realize okay there's some some
some cool stuff here and then you go in
and in again
but i feel it's like mostly it's like
really to see the contrast and to
actually see that
and it's actually it's a little bit
disappointment also to really realize
that i'm not getting any
anywhere even though how did i go but i
just
see that everything is and then there's
no distance to anything and
you can't get any perspective to
anything
so nothing makes sense anymore
whoa yeah that
so that's a big jump so let's let's play
with that big jump for a bit
so if we're visualizing this
vijay would it be fair to potentially
visualize it like
there's a there's a screen of perception
here there's a screen of perception
there and there's
we're gonna we're gonna get to the point
where there's no distance between them
but
okay so there's these screens of
perception that are happening
and then in a sense they all go to the
same
screen of perception so the same
witness is viewing the screens of
perception of the atlas soul and the
vj soul and etc so all of these screens
of perceptions
they merge are you following so far
right yeah yeah yeah
okay cool okay so the screens of
perception themselves
merge and so then they're in a sense
there becomes less and less distance
between what initially
was like hey that vj costume
souls all the way over in finland and
this one is all the way in california
and so my gosh there's so much distance
between them but when these screens of
perceptions come up to the same
great i am observation
that one god self then now they're
enough indescribably close to each other
okay so then you ask
well what is
witnessing or observing the
great i am of these 8 billion screens of
perception
and so then
the decision to enjoy carrots or
potatoes at the store
versus the deepest metaphysical absolute
truth
that you hang out with
five minutes later when you get back
home
those are equal in
value because everything is in a sense
falling into this
especially if you have invested a lot to
that your intelligence of
how am i personally
and we would probably go as far as to
say that
what we're mentioning right now is a
it's really valuable but it's valuable
for once you've in a sense mastered your
awareness of awareness itself like
don't jump to this point and this is
where
i have a strong stance on which i've
i i've relaxed this point of view but
it's still a strong
stance because in a sense i i'm really
passionate about
the global awakening and so in a sense
when
much of the neo advaita pointing is
really important and really
helpful and really insightful if in a
sense you
jump people to the place where
there's no point to seek because you're
already the absolute
it's it's a great way of viewing it
there's no distinction between you being
angry
and you being happy right but then what
are you doing is you're stripping people
away from sachitananda
and so yeah
yeah i think you're making a very
valuable point because
for me i would say that most
the three miracles in life what i would
say
the only miracles like if some
bearded guy walks on the water i don't
think that's any kind of miracle but
but to to really find
um right kind of master
is the first miracle actually the first
miracle is that
this urge to to find truth find freedom
arises in you and the second one is that
you find the right kind of master
and the third one is that you actually
follow this master
to the actual end what he's pointing to
because yeah because the mind
i mean you can when you hear something
like that that nothing matters or
like you said that this new i vita type
of teachings that
you so easily can make conclusions and
you can apply non-duality to your life
or something like that but
i feel that like in in
in the raw book he says
that the first number one first
important thing for
a human being is to to know his mind
so i i feel that if you have a master
that i think you need a master because
you get so arrogant with your own
processes and you think that you have
gone over
something but if you have right kind of
master is actually living master
then your [ __ ] gets like
shown pretty quickly so paradoxically
what to to what
i i described before i i really think
it's very healthy to have a good monster
it's vital yup
so learn to
hold both of these lenses at the same
time which is that
this is already ineffable perfection
this is already the absolute
i am already absolutely free this in
itself
is an announcement of freedom
okay okay great and then you hold that
simultaneously
with this okay well why am i angry
and why is sachitananda plastered all
over
enlightenment but why do i not feel any
satchitananda
and so then that's the process of being
like okay well
now i'm gonna have the seeking impulse
of finding a master
that has mastered both the fact that
this is ineffable absolute perfection
freedom already
and they are simultaneously helping
realign people repeatedly with
purification
away from egoic conditioning towards
sachitananda towards being in pure
service to others
and so then you're in a sense you're
following the master to the end because
it's not that
the end is just that this is already
free done
okay back we go to netflix
yeah it's that it's that this is already
absolute freedom and there's actually
a process of realignment and
purification
and to become a pure steward or
shepherd for the ignition of the
planetary enlightenment
yep yeah good description
yeah you too yeah
yeah this is a really good place to
in a sense maybe we'll play for a little
bit here and then we'll rap but this is
really the
big i would say one of the big
highlights of
our conversation is that
just perpetually know that you can't
be transparent to yourself
like that's a really good way to put it
and vijay was
very adamant about highlighting that in
our
nls fam and i think that that was
extremely insightful
and if you really truly follow that
thread of not being able to be
transparent to yourself and just
constantly wondering
you know where am i fraudulent where am
i full of [ __ ]
over and over and over again
and then following that thread
repeatedly because you're humbling
yourself through that entire process
you're in a sense you're surrendering to
the one intelligence
expressing itself through vj saying hey
atlas i think you might be a little bit
full of [ __ ] here
and then basically it's surrendering and
saying that you know thank you for this
reflection okay so
let's investigate am i truly full of
[ __ ] there
and so that
that process of not being able to ever
be fully transparent to yourself
and then getting to the point where you
recognize even when you are
very transparent to yourself that even
the sense of
i itself that you have to become more
and more transparent to how even
that is in itself an intoxicative
illusion
and that you've been perpetually
associating yourself
with the sense of i your entire life
and so that you then have to in a sense
disassociate
from to be able to commune with this in
a sense this last
sort of pop this last stage
and so you have to find the right
master to be able to navigate all of
these different lenses
or find multiple masters that know how
to navigate these different lenses and
then pull from them
into this navigable lattice work
[Music]
yeah and also i think that that um
this kind of purification process or
what you mentioned that to somehow
expose [ __ ]
and stuff like that i think also
it can become a trap in a way totally
that's that's something that i have like
a little bit been considering myself
that what what my
my view about this in in our
what the families know limits families
that because
it's quite simple uh the mooch is
pointing for example that that that you
always go to the i am and actually the
purification it's it's not the main
focus
but it's it's always like about exposing
the person
because the person is interested about
purification
but the absolute truth is is not
not the one that needs to be purified so
when your attention is always
directed to the absolute essence of what
you are then
you don't have to actually worry about
the purification effect
so much but also i have found very
valuable when bentino has
talked about this emotional guidance
system i think it's
it's very very beautiful way also to
somehow catch yourself but now i'm
arguing with god because there's this
kind of thing or something like that but
also
somehow not to go overboard with that
because sometimes
if god happens it's part of the
part of the game the very nature of
redirecting attention
is that realignment to the one heart
to the i am to the absolute repeatedly
and while you do that it's a
self purification engine mechanism
as you said yeah
yeah beautifully said so it's like
said something like
i leave my human nature
to unfold according to its own
tendencies
and i remain as i am
so he doesn't uh mind
what the human human form how it unfolds
but he remains as he is
something like that yeah it's fun to
yeah i like that a lot as well it's this
abiding repeatedly
in these pops so the more that you abide
as awareness itself
formless subtle impersonal eternal
the more that you dissolve the
person conditioning and then the more
that you
abide as that which is the source
of perception itself the more that you
dissolve the person conditioning and
even
that you dissolve perception itself
and yeah
yeah actually it's a magical magical
process because
many times when you just focus on that
essence of what you are some things that
you have thought about that
i want to purify this one day they
vanish like you don't even have to worry
about them at all it's just
at one night you don't even remember
that you had such a
issue with your personality or something
like that
but if you concentrate and focus on
some impurity that you have and you want
to get rid of it or somehow
it somehow also makes it
stronger and it becomes like an actual
thing when it
when you somehow disregard it it might
just fall away
some kind of negative tendency for
example
yeah yeah it's so it's it's as though
abiding
equals purification
yeah yeah what's that i kind of like
what's uh well set yeah that's a good
headliner
yeah that's a good one let's put that
one in there abiding
equals purification
wow and that's really what the
know yourself and accept yourself is
that really is that is the more that you
just bathe in this
right here
you can almost see the timelines
where there's one of them that is this
this person conditioning timeline as the
onion layer
and then there's the continuous abiding
timeline
and so to know yourself accept yourself
is to become more and more subtly aware
of when that other timeline is like
nope and you can yeah and then you just
abide
in this ineffable perfection
and it purifies you it is the
purification engine itself
and you become more and more of the
creator
as you do this process and you become
less and less of
the person conditioning and you become a
better and better steward
shepherd for igniting that planetary
awakening
[Music]
but also i have to add that
in the end even abiding is
exactly so of course it's a beautiful
dream but
yeah but you can't i don't know
i've noticed that i'm i'm still right
now at the
place where it's become really
helpful to in a sense like pop
back into witnessing or observing or
awareness and then
pop again into that impersonal
eternal all-inclusive awareness and then
pop again into
the ineffable that makes perception
i found that entire process to be in
itself
the core for abiding for
me and as i do that right now it
is
taking me so far away from person
conditioning
so that that's why it's in a sense uh
helpful but then you're right that at
some point even that
quote it's like sitting on a cushion you
you transcend sitting on a cushion
and now you're gonna transcend
eventually these
your little training wheels of abiding
yeah yeah and i think one of ben dinho's
uh favorite quotes that similar to what
i earlier said that also said that
meditation has to become your whole life
that painting yourself that
seek your ass off or something like that
exactly because
i mean if there's nothing
nothing else makes sense to to do
when you are alive and to seek that's
what how i feel that
if it's if it's abiding and purifying i
i think that's the most
beneficial work you can do and help
others to do that same thing too
yeah you'll you'll probably
find this to be
interesting
i'll go ahead and post it here
so perfectly pleased with what we just
said
he is born in vain who having attained
the human birth
so difficult to get does not attempt
to realize god in this very
life sri ramakrishna
amen what a perfect
rap
it's nice to play tennis with you
you too yeah oh
that like atlantic ocean yes
exactly yeah it's great in the physical
it's across this atlantic ocean and then
on this all-inclusive awareness
it's like indescribably already next to
each other yeah
yeah this was so nice so grateful vijay
thank you
thank you for coming on this program
thank you atlas thank you so much
for organizing and putting all this
together it's
beautiful it was so fun we
we had such a good time i i know that i
know that there were a lot of good
pieces of wisdom for others as well to
be able to take and
leverage i really loved our
let's see i'll bring some back up
our meditation has to become your whole
life
we had the beautiful i
am the one seeing it all
we had the manifest is such an amazing
mystery
we had uh how could
we know how could we know
the mystery we had the
sort of couple step
seeking impulse finding a right master
following the master to the end
we had the redirecting attention to the
i am absolute repeatedly
abiding equals purification
it's so many good ones in there
you are very skillful at collecting
those
fruits and fruits yeah yeah
yeah the tennis game has its beautiful
fruit that then we
share in this lattice work
yeah yeah very beautiful
and everyone you can find some links in
the bio below we'll have some stuff
there to
vj where's the best place to uh for
people to follow
you follow me
um i don't know
i have a youtube channel but not not so
much there
but me too there are i have some
crazy santa claus nondualistic stuff
there
maybe that's the place to start okay
excellent santa claus non-duality
we'll have that down there and we'll
have the no limit society link
as well for you guys to check out and
thanks everyone for tuning in
infinite adoration we love you very much
thank you
we would love to hear your thoughts in
the comments below on the episode let us
know
what you think and if the video brought
you value give it a like it helps the
algorithm subscribe if you haven't
already
share the interview the conversation
with people that
you feel like this would resonate with
and
that is all you beautiful souls
costumes units of the one intelligence
thank you so much
all right and thank you all right
beautiful vijay
you and i will stay in the studio and
i'll go ahead and end the broadcast
you